i knew a guy who had to like build a
nest while we were having sex
like he's put pillows all around us what
the [ __ ] and like blankets and pillows
he built a fort for you guys pretty much
[Music]
welcome back to big mood everyone
we have a beautiful guest here named
stacy diaz yay
yay okay so today oh and also duh
everybody else
really beautiful people
here as well i love you and you matter
who's here but am i beautiful
you're okay cheetah's here
uh nikki he's here present present and
tiffany
wait that was weird gross
like you're self editing yeah wait
i'm like wait no
[Laughter]
i don't know every time i call myself
tiffany it just feels great i love
tiffany tiffany blue yeah i get it i
never call myself nicole yeah
it's weird nice i know it just sounds
like my own trouble name in my head
though yeah
completely forgot that that's your real
name right same that's weird i never
remember it's my name nicole has grown
and exotic
when i have kids i'll introduce like to
their friends i'm
or to their parents i'll be like i'm
nicole green oh i like that yes
i like that and it sounds like gina and
stacey are short for other names regina
oh oh yeah wait it's like your vagina
vagina
i don't know what's the oh anastasia
that's what state is short for yeah okay
stacy comes from anastasia yeah why is
why is the nickname for richard dick i
know right i don't understand why the
nickname for william is bill wait what
about francisco do you guys know francis
what what yeah where do you get that
from i have no idea
i don't know everywhere
you know the flintstones what was the
flintstones name the dude the main guy
uh barney
okay in spanish his name is pedro
[Music]
i didn't know topher was short for
christopher yeah
topher who's going to october grace from
that 70s
oh yeah and i'm sorry guys you should
call yourself tofu ever
got sidetracked a bit sorry all right
guys so today we're going to be talking
about the mental blocks that women feel
that make it harder for them to enjoy
sex oh okay
so i have answers but go ahead yeah
all right so these are mental blocks
that women have encountered during sex
and so the first one says for me it's
the constant pressure that i need to
orgasm during sex if i'm constantly
asked are you gonna come yet it takes
away the pleasure part of it and i get
stressed the sex can't feel like a chore
either because if i don't feel the
intimacy part of it i lose all pleasure
i'm very into my emotions with sex so i
can't do emotionless sex at all foreplay
before helps build me up for a lot of
pleasure during sex and sometimes a
vibrator during penetration helps a lot
too
i relate a hundred percent to this i
relate partially
well okay i really
partially because i don't get asked uh
have you come yet oh that's the only
part i really
okay yeah like i don't like i had to
tell steve because before like i like
being dominated like she can relate and
uh one of the things that steve used to
do is be like
you gotta ask permission before you come
you know like that kind of thing and so
it's like are you going to come are you
going to come are you going to come you
better ask me better and i'm like look i
like the dominance part but i can't come
if you if it's interrupted like it's
like this process so if i'm like about
to come i can't stop and ask for it or
else it's just not gonna happen and so
he stopped asking me that and i started
coming again and
then i just feel rushed if you keep
asking yeah i feel right it's like let
me let me chill for a second and i feel
like you need it more than me and so i
want to make you feel better by coming
and so that's what led to faking orgasms
wait so
i feel like it's pretty apparent when
i'm done yeah is it not like i feel like
you could tell right like yeah like
happy to me yeah like can you not feel
anything
they want to know yeah exact moment that
they caused you to come or maybe they're
waiting for you to come so you can come
together because that's a beautiful
moment it is that is nice
i personally like that
i'm sure that's why i'm sure that that's
what the guy is thinking yeah that's who
they are that's what they're thinking
because i mean
if they know what it feels like they
know it's magical yeah okay it's a
moment of love it's only happening once
in my life really what like at the same
time yeah um oh yeah
pretty sure wow
yeah don't don't rush me like i'll be
yeah i'll get there when i get there and
you'll be able to tell you're gonna know
when i get there stop stop i also prefer
coming orally first oh and then the sex
feels way better and i'm able to get
there faster so that's where my mental
block comes from because it's very hard
for me to come orally
so
like if it for a while i would struggle
like oh god is it taking too long are
you tired i'm so sorry like you don't
have to do this you know oh yeah yeah me
too you have to be reassured by them
that they're like no i don't care yeah
it takes you know just take your time
don't even think about it like i had to
be really reassured with that and i also
um i have to think about things while i
do it like i need to have like pictures
playing that turn me on while i am
being taken care of yeah like what do
you picture can i know picture like
really
disgusting scenarios okay but with
no i'm picturing being completely
dominated got it yeah that's like your
thing yeah because it was like getting
completely dominated well but he's when
he's down there i don't feel dominated
exactly yeah dominant because he's it's
almost like he's down there yeah so i
have to in my head be feeling like i'm
being forced to do something or like
whatever i'm being like submissive in
that way yeah interesting
okay next one
i shared a bedroom with my sister and a
paper thin wall with my mother growing
up i also broke the bathroom's lock to
force my sister out of the bathroom one
morning and it took me very long a very
long time to get the money to buy a new
one and then learn how to replace it so
i basically had no privacy when i was at
the age you discover your own body okay
that's what all that was like i was like
what kind of stuff is going on
so my boyfriend broke a lock one time
and it really just said
um okay so then she says i was always
super afraid of being hurt or walked in
on and it stayed with me until today i
need to be sure to have complete and
total privacy to relax enough to finish
i relay hard to this really especially
because well mine's
sad but
i've had a lot of trauma with my privacy
so yeah i completely i completely
relate to this so what do you have to do
to make sure you're like
like for example can
do you guys have to be at home alone
have you seen their bedroom they have
like 16 dead bolts in the on the door
that's crazy it's true
yeah
for that reason like that's why i've
talked about in the past where like
quiet sex is what really turns me on or
at least you used to turn me on because
now i'm i'm not really there anymore
fully because i think i've outgrown
like a lot of this trauma like there's
been more time i've been going to
therapy like it doesn't have to be
completely quite vocal huh but it will
only be vocal though if we're the only
people who are poor
washing
[Music]
i'm so sorry isaac i just i'm sorry
well he's doing it too
no but yeah so then so it's that right
like me
through that trauma i had to like
have quiet sex i had to make sure that
we're completely alone because of that
reason too
like for example when we go on vacation
and you know we'll have friends that are
like we're sharing an airbnb together
and there'll be people that are like oh
yeah we're gonna go [ __ ] or whatever
it's like whatever who said something
like these two yeah i mean i don't
announce it i don't know
i'm not saying they're announcing
they had sex in the room next to me and
i thought the earth was shaking and i
cried
we really thought there was people like
stomping up the stairs because it was
like you're sick to sexy music i'm
telling you but never leave my life
never in my life i've ever thought i
would hear steve green orgasm but here
we are
i'm so embarrassing that's your fault
for hearing boundaries batteries
boundaries
we were very drunk
did you make sure everybody else was
drunk please love me
everybody take shots no and then go they
should provide they should provide
goodie bags with earplugs lots of money
oh kind of like the parents that have
their toddler in the airplane well they
weren't even safe and they were they
were two levels above two levels the
not even just like them right like you
know we've we've have shared homes with
other couples right like oh yeah we did
it last night or whatever the [ __ ] i
think we did it's different than we're
on our way yeah
i exaggerated
i exaggerated
the house
yeah it's different
i hear it
let me clear that up the point is
other people can have sex where their
friends are in the same home yeah i
can't i could
i can't i'm not announcing it but as
long as you're not in the same room yes
no i can't i can't in the same house
because you like if we go on vacation
and we're there three weeks you're not
going to do it no wow really
yeah holy so remind me i needed a shower
to a bush or something you know what
when i was in the shower like when i was
younger though and like when i had i was
more way more hornier like i could
but
no now it's like we're married we have
our own house we could wait like
chill you know see i get turned on um
like i've tried to get steve to have sex
with me in public because
like in restrooms like like where we
could get caught where there's like the
possibility of getting kind of
i love that [ __ ] but he hates it that's
a scary pink girl you could be like uh
what is it called defender yeah you
could be registered as a sex offender if
you get caught it's consensual sex
between two people and you could still
get registered public i'll be like i
don't know him
no not even worse
[Music]
if the cop was understanding i'd be like
we've been having problems and i didn't
know we were gonna make up right here
right now but i just got caught in the
moment
but you know what i'm inconsistent
because i could have sex in the car
maybe because that's private it's
probably there's no one else yeah okay
you don't publicly you can't get walked
in by your anyone that you know yeah and
it's your car so you feel like it's your
space yeah that's true yeah yeah
but there's nothing wrong with you i
mean everybody has their preferences
yeah i knew a guy who had to like build
a nest while we're having sex
like he's put pillows all around us what
the [ __ ] and like blankets and then
pillows he built a fort for you guys
yeah that was pretty much that's the
first time we had sex i was like
no you're like yeah you also have to
wear
jammies
wait what was your question did he also
have to wear batman jammies like
for the parameters
he hangs up lights i'm like wait a
picture of the sport being built as
you're having sex and then you didn't
realize until you finished
with your look i was like wait you
didn't know this was happening she
looked around she's like
wow
because i realized while he was on top
he was pulling pillows all around like
okay but then like we would like shift
around and like when i'm on top he would
also grab pillows okay so he was [ __ ]
building yeah
so he was building a looking at this
thing yeah so and then afterwards like i
noticed that the first time we had sex
afterwards i was like
so you you build a little nest when
you're having sex he's like yeah i like
to be comfortable oh that's funny he's
done judging his race really cute
yeah it's adorable so yeah i'm just here
to judge and
and be supportive at least there's a man
that has extra pillows around i get [ __ ]
for that true
people my husband bags on me for having
so many pillows but this man yeah i can
relate to you can't do that one flat
yellow pillow
you
gross so no one else relates with the
privacy thing um i think personally
no
no but the only thing is for example
obviously i have a roommate and
my fiance stays over all the time and so
that's not a problem for us to me it's
just kind of like well i'm in my own
personal space and we're doing our thing
like if we were to go on vacation i
would try to be quiet i'm not gonna be
like woo yeah but i mean well so then at
home you're whoo
like if your sister's home
yeah
i mean to him you know it's not like i'm
like hear me everybody in the
neighborhood but i'm still enjoying my
experience and making sure he's enjoying
his experience because it's my home you
know
and i think that's your moment that you
have with each other and if we were to
go on vacation and like we all went and
we had our own room i would just be like
okay let's try to be a little more quiet
but yeah i'm not not going to do it
because there's people in the house you
know because i love having yeah i don't
want to feel inhibited in my own house
yeah but i've also haven't dealt with it
because so you were with your family and
then you had isaac yeah like you said
you've never lived alone never i went
from living with a boyfriend to living
with a boyfriend to living with a
husband like so i've never lived with
roommates or anything my house is my
house i've only had my house with my
boyfriend yeah the only time i had to
sneak around was when i was in high
school living with my parents that was
my whole life it was inhibiting like i
didn't like that i felt oppressed i felt
sexually oppressed so we go to the back
of to the parking lot of the costco and
yeah i did a lot of car sex
and i had pillows and i had um the thing
that blocks the windshield oh yeah i
made up my own little fort in my car and
we also had like um like the whole so
the back seat was like set up like a
couch and it had blankets and it was
like yeah comfy and he was short so like
it
worked it worked
short
couldn't do that with steve i'm like i
don't mind sex in public or other people
in the house but for some reason i get
like
i really don't want you guys to hear me
so i try to be really quiet yeah because
i don't know i don't know it's like a
whisper courteous yeah yeah yeah i don't
i don't want i don't want people to hear
me if i'm
not around other people
[Laughter]
i don't control her
or like even if the bed's making too
much noise i'm like oh that's yeah i
feel that yeah that takes me out that's
a mental block for me like if the bed is
shaking too much or it's too crazy or
like you can get up yeah like i i'm like
removed from sex unless he reassures me
like oh i don't care you're so hot let's
whatever i'm like i can't do it because
we share a wall with our neighbors right
here and that's where our bed leans up
against and like i told you like since
we changed the carpet out for hardwood
floors upstairs the bed moves completely
so it smells like our cabinets as soon
as it starts hitting yeah i do get taken
out of it and i'm like yeah the
neighbors did everything like don't wake
them up i just think it's rude to be
woken up on a weekday like at after
midnight at any time and that's usually
like when it's happening so it's nice
yeah i don't like that consider it yeah
be considerate and if i was in public i
definitely wouldn't want to be caught
it's the possibility of being caught so
i wouldn't be loud
secret secret
yeah yeah so the hotness of that
is kind of like me but then the consider
the considerate part of it is overly
with me
yeah that will take you out of the
section like did i make sense because i
didn't really say a lot of words but
yeah
i feel you you're about your feelings
are valid yeah regardless of what they
are thank you
for those of you who are boning
you don't want to have crotch goblins
i'm looking at you
oh there's about to have two
there's the pill club it's a birth
control delivery service uh if you're on
birth control remembering take your pill
is already enough work that's why i got
the implant
in my arm because if i had to remember
to take pills i would be pregnant every
month you have to associate it with a an
activity you do every day like brushing
your teeth it's like i brush my teeth my
pill yeah uh so forget going to the
doctor in person to get your
prescription and picking it up from the
pharmacy the pill club wants to help
take the work out of taking care of
yourself uh the pill club is a birth
control subscription prescribed by a
medical professional and delivered
straight to your door for free so you
don't have to go
to those doctor appointments anymore and
wait for three hours long the pill club
carries over 120 fda approved brands
most brands of birth control are free
with insurance or medicaid otherwise
prices start as low as seven dollars a
month without insurance the pill club
delivers birth control to your door for
free and discreet packaging and their
licensed medical team is just a text
away to give you the best reproductive
health care so skip the office visit and
waiting in line at the pharmacy and join
the club right now when you go to the
pillclub.com big mood the pill club is
offering a 10 donation to bedsider.org
for every big mood listener who becomes
a patient
your donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org and we love that
yeah
that's the pillclub.com
big mood to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember it's
thepillclub.com
big mood and you must use the link to
make the donation help someone out
yeah nobody no babies crawling out of
you all right
it's too late
yeah it's so scary
i love your baby thank you okay good
so you can get your birth control
delivered right to your door and also
you can get food with doordash don't get
them mixed up
doordash connects you with restaurants
you love right now and right to your
door and now you can get the grocery
essentials you need with doordash too
get drinks snacks and other household
items delivered in under an hour
ordering is super easy you just open the
doordash app you choose what you want
from where you want and your items will
be left safely outside your door with
the contactless delivery drop-off
setting with over 300 000 partners in
the u.s puerto rico canada and australia
you can support your neighborhood
go-to's or choose from your favorite
national restaurants like popeyes
wednesdays chipotle chipotle and
cheesecake factory there we go
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
mood that's 25
off up to a 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code mood don't forget
that's code mood for 25 off your first
order with doordash subject to change
terms apply yay all right next one
ladies let's see this one says
until a few years ago i couldn't orgasm
from sex with a partner only through
masturbation this was due to the
inability to trust men fully and to give
myself completely because i was sexually
assaulted as a teen that's totally
understandable i know
100 and also like
like a lot of women don't orgasm during
intercourse like it's not like 10 needs
to be normalized yeah exactly can we
normalize that because it's like yeah
you can't like you can
and like after a certain point of doing
it like maybe you get used to doing it
or some women do but it's not like
every woman can just orgasm isn't there
like a low percentage of women that yeah
that actually orgasm from vaginal
intercourse concentration yeah from
penetration most women need the clitoris
yeah
because the dick has to hit it just
exactly right and has to hit it
repetitively enough to you orgasm
vaginally otherwise it's easier to do it
clearly it is
yeah yeah there's way more nerves there
and it's easier to access it's the only
organ men to make you orgasm men don't
have that
oh they have a prostate right they do
but their clitoris i think the clitoris
is the organ meant for that like it's
like a little button there for you to
orgasm like it has no other purpose but
yeah that's why in certain like certain
countries or maybe even religions i
can't remember right now they'll they'll
castrate with you yeah yeah
it's so yeah it's like
jeez
i have to orgasm
literally
um
clearly
um and i actually prefer doing it myself
during sex like while we're having sex
because like it's because he's behind
yeah or like a missionary also oh and
it's it's like
simply because it's just more convenient
you know it's like i can get us work
faster
and do you ever use toys yeah yeah
so it's just it's just easier that way
and i don't have to worry about oh this
is taking too long for me like i don't
want you have to worry about it but also
like we were saying earlier not every
woman can orgasm easily and then
whenever a guy a lot of times and guys
are like well you know i like am i not
good enough or whatever yeah they mean
they take it personally yeah it's it
puts the pressure on us oh yeah that's
why we fake it yeah so we have to fake
that that's where all the fake news is
to save your pride
so
like if a woman doesn't orgasm during
sex with you like it's it could be
pretty normal you know yeah it is
extreme orgasm i mean
intercourse doesn't require an orgasm
you can have sex without an orgasm and
that's okay you know a lot of people
think that that's the end goal of
intercourse but it's not you know not
for everybody i follow a sex therapist
on instagram and she always makes this
little post you know that talk about
different things and for some people
they don't even want the orgasm they
just want the connection the connection
yeah everybody's different of course
we're not gonna shame anybody for their
personal sexual experience but there is
a lot of pressure on the orgasm yes i
think for men the majority of the times
that is their end goal yeah
for myself i don't need it all the time
i just want the connection to feel the
closeness and if it happens great which
when you're having sex it's better to go
at it from that perspective rather than
come come yeah yeah go right now go
right now be free to do this yeah
because you're gonna have to be relaxed
into it mm-hmm totally agree because
even for the guys too like
they'll even get mental blocks because
of the pressure too like yeah
they also experience it yeah
what was it called a non-concordance
something remember i talked about yeah
you did
um
come as you are come as you are by emily
nagowski highly recommend it if you want
to learn about women's sex uh
experiences of [ __ ] science about it
whatever
science people i'm not saying facebook
nerds
anyway
i actually want to reread that book
because like i feel like i i
read it and i
you've gotten into some of the comments
i got some of it but i'm feeling like
i'm missing so much of it yeah like i
saw him with a lot of books yeah because
you kind of need like you'll read the
same book again and you get new
information because you only retain a
certain amount of information from what
you read that's true yeah all right next
one this one says for me feelings of
guilt slash pressure can get in the way
penetrative sex doesn't do it for me but
other acts like oral
make it so that i'm i'm the only one
receiving pleasure which makes me feel
guilty
additionally being the sole focus can
make me feel anxious and pressured to
orgasm this person is taking the time to
do something especially for me so i must
make it worth their while that's kind of
what you were saying gina
and then so that's where nikki said
earlier they just need the reassurance
no you're not taking too long and i can
be down here all day don't worry and
that makes us feel better exactly you
know or like tell us like i don't want
to stop until you can turn that part of
your mind off yeah yeah the reassurance
actually really helps that's so
interesting why do we feel that like
what is wrong with receiving right
because i think we're naturally the
caregivers yeah you know and like
biologically like we're the nurturers
we're the caregivers we're the ones like
making sure things are okay we're the
protective mama bears but yeah in the
bedroom it should be reciprocated
yeah but it's hard for us to turn that
part of our brain off because we're so
wired to
make sure everyone's okay and we're
taking care of everyone yeah for me
too like
i would i just prefer penetrative sex
over or you feel more connected right
yeah it's like quite literally yeah yeah
your body is in my body yeah so like
sometimes i'll just be like it's okay
you know i'll just pull them up i'm like
it's okay let's do that let's get this
started
i have to be in the right head space for
oral whereas like so
the so sex for me i told steve this all
the time that like i just like the
thoughts to be [ __ ] out of my head
where like he like he's having sex with
me so hard that like my brain can't
think of thoughts i can't be worried
about anything like i feel so like
forced into the present because of
how good the sex is and i love that part
whereas like the oral like i have to be
thinking about stuff i have to be
thinking of pictures and things that
turned me on yeah yeah that's true i'm
like hey we're good today
just [ __ ] the thoughts out of my head
yeah
i'm like grabbing his hand come up yeah
come on join me come to the promised
land
all right uh next one
i've only been able to orgasm with my
fiance but even then it's hit or miss i
can only like 50
of the time i think my past partners i
wasn't really attracted to them or they
didn't fulfill me emotionally but with
my fiance sometimes the dogs are barking
their heads off in the backyard or a
good episode of supernatural is playing
in the background or i'm thinking about
what i want for dinner i get distracted
easily and it takes a lot of focus
sometimes i do i do best early in the
mornings when i'm sleepy and not worried
about other things or right after
a shower when i'm relaxed
oh that's the end of the sentence yeah
okay
um
yeah i mean that's so natural because i
think yeah as women's we as women we
multitask yeah and we can think of a
thousand things at once
and i think the majority of men can only
think at one thing at a time so when
they're focused on that that is their
whole focus yeah and that is why a lot
of men are visually turned on literally
they see you boom that's it they're
right yeah yeah to where us the majority
of the time we're like i need you to
tell me i'm pretty sensual and then
touch me and hug me and then 20 minutes
i'll be into it
that's where the whole like give me a
back robe comes in yeah that is very
true because i remember in a
relationship my guy was like
you know i feel like you haven't really
been into sex lately and i'm like
yeah because my whatever just died yeah
yeah
oh
yeah they don't get it because they can
only think it one thing at a time
you know or even like like if we ever
have an argument my partner knife we
have an argument
he'll want to mend things with sex and
yeah it's like we can't love each other
yes
let's hug for an hour and then possibly
i can think about this but to them
that's a way to fix things for me at
least it's always been like well let's
fix it cuddle love each other and then
we can get into it right yeah yeah
that's interesting for me it's so weird
though the only way i've ever been able
to just jump right into makeup sex is if
the relationship itself was toxic like
there was no mending and all we had was
the sex yeah the sex felt so good
because that's all the good thing you
have exactly compatibility elsewhere in
life no yeah
i will just be a [ __ ] nun
if the relationship is [ __ ] there is no
[ __ ] because i didn't know the
difference between compatibility and
chemistry which a lot of people get
confused with they think oh if i have
really good sex with this person we
connect in the bedroom like we're
compatible nope and you can also like
really connect everywhere else in life
except for the bedroom and that means
you have no chemistry and
the goal would be to find someone that
fulfills both or at least like in a
balanced way maybe a little bit of well
and sex you can always get better at
yeah with your partner that's like a
thing you can work on and communicate
you know people expect it to just be
like a spark where everything's magic
but sometimes you can work your way to
better sex although if there's nothing
there though
you're in trouble yeah i mean you're
probably not even you wouldn't be dating
yeah because like well i mean i'm one of
my earlier boyfriends the one that i
moved to l.a with um we were dating for
five years and
you know the first year and a half you
know i liked sex but it was just like
the newness of a new guy right but and
then he was great
on paper like we were compatible we had
the same views in life but i just never
wanted to have sex with him like i just
was not he always wanted to have sex and
then he would take it really personally
and i would tell him it's not personal
but i i didn't know that it actually was
personal because i actually just wasn't
attracted to him sexually like there
just wasn't any chemistry in the bedroom
but i loved him
i loved him i was just wasn't maybe in
love with him
in that way but i didn't know that
because it was so young so you don't
know you're like wait what's wrong with
me is this how all relationships are
because you know people are always like
oh once you get married the sex dies
that's not true by the way um but you
know i can see how that's true for a lot
of people because it's like
maybe they weren't
chemists they were compatible but they
didn't have the chemistry and they
thought that that was just how it was
yeah
cause i almost married him thinking that
like we get along and we're comfortable
and we're compatible what if i never
find that again
no the sex so yeah i guess we could work
on it but it just wasn't like it made me
want to puke thinking about oh geez
having sex yeah that's pretty bad yeah i
had a relationship like that too where
it's like we were talking about marriage
and he was like about to buy a ring and
then
when he said that he's like i want to
marry you i'm saving up to get a ring
the first thought in my head was
well i mean couples eventually stopped
having sex anyways yeah you know i know
and then i caught myself i was like what
am i thinking yeah it's ingrained in us
yeah yeah so that's why i never followed
through i was like i can't see myself
being with someone who i don't enjoy sex
with
yeah absolutely that's so true it's a
key component at least for me not
everyone you know it depends on your
relationship and stuff but i feel like
to be fulfilled like i i need passion i
need that
you know that i want to rip your clothes
off sex thing okay next one
i feel a mental block when there's
something really off with the person i'm
having sex with especially if i don't
feel love affection or passion coming
from that person while we're having it
if i feel the person is doing it like
it's some kind of chore then it's very
hard for me to orgasm right or i just
can't that makes sense for sure we can
tell too you can tell when someone's
just like going through the motions yeah
yeah
that doesn't make you feel good as a
person
also um
not even just like the chore one but
also like having sex just to have sex
and not even like for me personally and
not not connecting yeah then i'm like oh
i'm not into this like at all
yeah like emotionless sex like what a
person earlier said yeah yeah where it's
just like oh i'm just trying to get off
yeah no i can't do that i can't get off
then yeah yeah unless it's like a hookup
it's just lust but that's not a
relationship
right i remember like um one of the guys
that i've dated before like he was like
one of my first boyfriends in high
school
and there was this one day where i was
like i was sick i had like a cold
and
he was like are you sure you can't have
sex though oh and i was like all right
this relationship's over we're not doing
this anymore right yeah his first
instinct wasn't like what can i get you
right yeah damn yeah or like that's the
same i feel like that's the same thing
as like when you when a woman gives
birth and the first thing the guy asks
the doctor is like so when can she have
sex again yeah right like that if you if
i ever hear that [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] i'm
stabbing you with something in there or
like i hear about nurses or whatever
doctors all the time where the husband
says oh can you give her the husband's
stitch yeah they want to they want to
knock you out when you say that
i have heard of that yeah i've seen some
posts online where it's like the woman
just just gave birth and
so i remember seeing the sick talk where
she was recording her baby daddy
sleeping on the hospital bed and she's
like he asked to switch places because
he was so tired being up all night while
i was giving birth and she actually did
it what the [ __ ] comments were like she
did it yeah why and then it's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
for me right run how like imagine
telling your baby mama that just gave
birth saying i'm tired can i lay in the
bed instead oh my god okay that's really
bad but i did hear
uh because the baby was crying so i'm
like oh cute can you hand me the big i
just had a [ __ ] c-section like he had
me the baby he was like oh
can't you get him oh my god i'm like
what
yeah excuse me like the baby's just been
born you could have already expected
where do they make dudes like this
okay to give a little credit he was like
[ __ ] delusional because i'm so tired
i don't want to shut up
no i don't want to [ __ ] on him too hard
but do you know him personally
his brother
yeah oh
wait this was your story yeah oh i
thought somebody you knew oh lord oh i
was like i just had a c-section oh my
he's like can't you get him i'm like are
you kidding me i yelled at him he was
like oh when he got up he was like oh
yeah he was just like out of it but i
[ __ ] heard that though i'm like what
what's my mind i did tell y'all for
steve to turn off my alarm this morning
and he wasn't in the room i was like
get it
but honey yeah
can you get back in the room
well you didn't just have a baby no
i was just saying i was delusional
though
i hadn't i wasn't awake exactly i didn't
realize he wasn't there wow
okay next one this one's a little long
it says i was on an antidepressant that
killed my sex drive which my partner was
initially understanding about but but
then when we did have sex it was a
massive deal to him i began dreading the
conversation that followed about how
great the sex was and how we should do
it more often because i just proved
that i could do it if i tried which made
made me feel pressured to have sex which
killed my sex drive even more it was a
vicious cycle and it killed our
relationship because every time we were
intimate non-sexually like parentheses
just as laying in bed cuddling i felt
that he was only doing it to hopefully
lead to sex it got to the point where it
was causing arguments in every aspect of
our relationship and i ended things
yeah i mean i think the common theme
here is pressure right yeah so much
pressure yeah it is yeah i mean that's
kind of tough because for example when
somebody is
medically
not wanting to have sex like in this
scenario obviously in a partnership
there's two people and the other person
also wants their needs met so when do
you give and when do you take and at
what point is too much from either end
because you can expect a sexual being
that is your partner to just go without
sex for the rest of their lives right
you know at some point i feel like it's
not forced but you do have to make an
effort to try and meet their sexual
needs because if i feel like there's
this thing in lesbian couples that's
called i forgot what it's called but
eventually it said that
older lesbian couples go without sex
because neither women want it like
they're comfortable without it they're
like meh i don't really want sex i don't
really want sex because in heterosexual
relationships the majority of the time
it's the man yeah who's pushing for it
like oh come on let's go let's go we're
like oh i'll rub your feet i'll do
whatever you want i'll buy you a cake or
whatever
um yeah or whatever turns you on
and it's interesting
because at what point
do you give too much or do you push
yourself to be like all right i'll i'll
pull my best foot forward and at what
point is he like you know like when does
the relationship fall apart yeah who's
giving too much and who's not getting
enough
yeah that's kind of my question i guess
i would say i think that's super valid
because um like i said like you said in
all lesbian relationships like they're
like mom we don't need it so if both
parties agree that they don't really
need that that's not an important factor
in their life then
cool yeah you're compatible yeah it
works but if you know
if you need sex like most people do
it's
i i think it's to me it's a deal breaker
and i've it has been a deal breaker
before like that one boyfriend i was
like on that end of i didn't want sex
and so i it was really hard for me to
break up with him because there was
nothing wrong in our relationship but i
knew it wasn't the right fit because i
want to have sex yeah um just not with
him and then i was in another
relationship where he didn't want to
have sex with me and i constantly wanted
to have sex and we had to break up
because i was like
this isn't going to work like
i need that that's something that makes
me feel loved physical touch
makes me feel loved it's one of my love
languages yeah so yeah it's just all
dependent on the people in the
relationship but
it's hard when one party wants it and
the other one doesn't yeah and i think a
lot of times all well
couples who have been married for a long
time run into this issue where the for
the majority of the time the wife is the
one that's like i could really go
without it for once every two weeks once
a month
and of course healthy relationships
quote unquote should probably be having
sex more often than that and obviously
the husband is in this place where
they're like i want it all the time and
the more you keep it away from me the
more that i want it
so i think it's i don't have the answer
for it i don't really i don't either i
haven't read enough about the topic but
it's just very interesting how as women
a lot of the times we fall into this
slower cycle and men are like on a
faster
like need
yeah it's swung both ways for me um so i
don't know if it's it's men and women
because like
currently like our past dry spell was
like you know me wanting it all the time
but he uh threw out his back and he had
like physical pain and he's not very
vocal when he's in pain so i didn't know
how bad it was and i was just getting
upset that we weren't having sex more um
but i understand that like i don't know
like i've also been on the other end
where i was the one not wanting sex uh i
think in either case if i'm the only if
i'm on the end where the other person's
pressuring me it makes me want it less
and less and less yeah and if i'm on
this i'm getting denied it it makes me
want it more and more and more and both
ends are so frustrating yeah i'm that
person like in the beginning of sex i
mean
in the beginning of the relationship i
want sex all the time yeah and then
after a while it's like okay it simmers
down it simmers down but then they still
really want it yeah and then that is a
little bit of pressure too it's just
like oh crap i have to perform you know
and like it's it's not anything personal
it's just now i'm like i love you and
yeah
you know yeah i think a lot of women can
relate to that that's true yeah
steve has a theory that once you get too
involved in a relationship um people
start letting their guards down and it
ruins the magic of sex like um you know
bathroom habits and uh i agree with that
exactly me too i'm a converter because i
used to think yeah the thing everyone
thinks is like once you're comfortable
around each other you can fart you can't
no no no no no
yeah no but honestly this is the first
time that we have kept that [ __ ] secret
and i want sex more than ever and we've
been together for almost almost ten
years yeah i don't have a fart in front
of my significant me neither
and there's
do your significant others fart in front
of you yes see that's the thing yeah
that's the best and you're the one where
this exercise first right
yeah
because like you kind of see them as
like
you're like my dad now yeah you're
crying in front of me you're like my
brother you're like my dad it becomes
less like you're putting an effort from
your translation put your best foot
forward right yeah there has to be some
sort of magic yeah like a curtain of
mystery yeah i don't want to look behind
it i full and agree with that now yeah i
believe i used to fight him on it i
always be like come on like that can't
be real he's like no i swear yeah and i
don't care what you think i'm never
going to let you hear me fart or smell
my heart yeah he lights a candle he
never
i never have smelled anything or heard
anything yeah
i was the one who introduced that idea
in our relationship because of my
previous relationships i'm like i
immediately got disgusted by them and
like hearing them fart and just having
them like purposely do it too and just
like
disrespectful oh no so i'm like
i yeah like early on in our relationship
i'm like like no can we not go there i
don't want to ruin it even if you're
like a chill girl because i was like
whatever i'm cool like he farts okay
whatever but no like it subconsciously
deteriorates
whatsoever
here i live by that what about
because for me personally i'm like i
could pee in front of him he could be in
front of me yeah
if you're in the bathroom and the other
partner happens to hear it that's on
them yeah like you're in the bathroom
yeah yeah doing close everything
you can't help yeah danny won't be in
front of me either he doesn't like it
yeah yeah but i'll p i i pee all the
time like ever since i was a child like
i need to pee everywhere like i've
we're literally even driving to vegas
one time and i had to pull over twice
like my vlog is this small yeah yeah so
i feel like it's just
a little better you know the whole
farting thing to me it's just
disgusting it smells yeah i don't want a
picture i don't want to smell it like i
literally lick you i don't want to yeah
i'm all about smells too and dude and in
the past and i'd be vocal about this i
got ridiculed but whatever i'm glad i'm
around people that agree now the most
successful relationship i've ever had is
like we have not farted around each
other and i want to bone his body yeah
or his bone and my body i don't know i
have to like do i have to like just
halfway through the relationship just
call them up and be like hey i just
learned something new today yeah
honestly yeah
no more fighting yeah
speaking of healthy habits developing
good habits not the ones that are farty
uh neum is one of our sponsors today and
they are a healthy habit weight loss
program um i don't know about you but
i've tried a lot of restrictive programs
from calorie counting to um you know
keto to
so many of those like restrictive ones
where you're just like what can i eat
you know and then i learned that it's
not necessarily what you're eating if
you're having a balanced diet but more
so your bad habits that are help that
are inhibiting you from reaching your
goals and a lot of times we don't know
what our bad habits are especially if
they're psychological so what gnome does
is it takes your goals and it helps you
understand
why you're doing the things you're doing
like for example i would stress eat all
the time and i didn't realize i was
doing that until i broke down like what
i was eating and when and the reason why
i was eating it and it really made me
think like oh my god like how often have
i done this and not even realize that i
was just overeating throughout the day
and then it works to break those blocks
and help you develop good habits it
takes 10 minutes a day
um they personalize it to what your
goals and habits are it uses a cognitive
behavioral approach which focuses on the
y instead of the what to help change
your relationship with food and
everybody's journey looks different noom
customizes a program for you based on
your personal goals and eighty percent
of new users finish the program and over
sixty percent have stuck with their
goals for at least a year start building
better habits for healthier long-term
results sign up for your trial at
noom.com big mood that's n o o m dot com
slash big mood again to sign up for your
trial go to noom.com
big mood we talked about butts a lot
today butts
and farting oh yeah yes but also what
else what else happens in butts
for those of you out there who hate
pooping and you have to wipe like 16
times i'm sorry check your diet but
hello also shave your butthole yeah oh
dingleberries yup you if you have
dingleberries
we need to save this relationship
use a razor and then get a bidet yeah
you should get the hello tissue bidet
uh hello tissue is the modern bidet for
people who poop
all you have to do is just poop wash and
pat dry you'd have to wipe so many times
it washes your butt with water for a
better clean than toilet paper and
washing is less irritating
and more soothing for your butthole it's
also easy to install it attaches in
under 10 minutes and you don't need
electricity or plumbing
and also you save money because hello
tissue bidet reduces your toilet paper
use by 80 percent um and hella tissue
doesn't only have bidets they have a
hello tissue ottoman which is the
sleekest toilet stool designed to help
you poop at 100
out there yeah and then they also have
the hello tishi brush it's the toilet
bowl brush the only one with disposable
scrubbing pads so you can use a clean
brush every time which makes sense
so start washing with a hella tissue
bidet for a better clean go to
hellotissue.com big mood to get 10 off
plus free shipping uh this is a special
offer for all of our listeners at
hellotishie.com big mood for 10 off and
after you buy and install your hello
tissue show it off tag us big mood and
at hello tishi on instagram
yeah that way i can judge you and i'll
know that you have a clean
mind all right next one
in order to orgasm i need to be able to
solely focus on the sensations i'm
feeling this is so mean yeah i can't i
can't talk about it think about anything
okay let me finish this one okay a
mental block is anything that stops me
from being able to achieve that focus i
think of it as something that takes me
out of the moment the mental block i've
encountered most frequently in the past
is if i'm hooking up with someone for
the first time and i'm really concerned
about whether he's enjoying himself
thinking too much about whether he's
enjoying it i can't properly enjoy it
myself i haven't found a way to overcome
it per se but if i only sleep with
people who i know value my pleasure then
i can more easily let go let myself go
and enjoy the moment thousand percent me
like solely focus on sensations that's
why like when i masturbate and stuff
like i don't i don't ever look up porn
or like i i don't need external
stimulation i just need to focus on my
own sensations i'm jealous of that i
definitely need a mental picture in my
head of
things going on or like
hearing like words being said or
something like that yeah that's your
visual and then you're sensitive yeah
yeah
yeah but that's valid yeah totally and
it also makes sense that if she's going
to partners who she's been with before
she's comfortable so it's maybe more a
comfort thing because when you're with
somebody new i'm sure you're like oh my
god is he does this person like this
does they do they not do i look like
this do i look like that
see that's why you need a partner who
has a dick that can [ __ ] your thoughts
out
and you don't think about any of that
i've read so many times that there are
like women are so
um self-conscious about their bodies
about their roles and how they look like
in bed and stuff and it affects them so
bad they can't enjoy sex but i've read
many articles or people just say that or
guys say that what turns me on is when
she's just confident completely
confident let loose and enjoy herself
yeah yeah but i understand it's hard i
think the mindset shift has to be like
it's for your pleasure as well as him so
yeah he just got to be there for you
enjoying it they wouldn't be there if
they didn't want to be yeah yeah yeah i
think also half the time at least from
my experience it's always
felt like they feel lucky to be there
yeah so you know treat it that way like
you could have enough confidence in
yourself to know that it is a pleasure
to experience you yeah and this person
is happy to be here you're not doing
them any favors and they're not doing
you any favors and they're not like oh
my god how horrendous i have to do this
i don't think any man that
i mean i'm sure none of you guys have
had that experience right all men are
like oh my god you wonderful thing thank
you for letting me enter you
right you know what though that whole
thing about being self-conscious about
what they think
because like i especially when i was
younger and like when casey and i first
started dating like i was so
self-conscious of how i felt i looked
like but it i don't know how to explain
it but it wasn't really about what he
thought of what i look i mean obviously
it was but you just wanted to put your
best foot forward it was more of me
judging myself and like me
me visualizing what he was looking at
damn girl
you were nowhere near the sexual
experience no no we're all in here no
[ __ ] yeah i was like so in here to the
point where it led to
like us incorporating a pillow
in our sex act during that time because
that was the only way i could even enjoy
something where was the pillow on your
face his oh
whoa
wait you were like you ugly thing
no don't bring back the [ __ ] hashtag
that's in the past and i'm just sharing
my my experience because like that was
what had that was like that was a
solution to help me get out of my own
head so he couldn't see you yes i
thought because he was like you were
like you hideous thing
no no it wasn't for that i mean yeah
like that was like the improv blindfold
it was like yeah like can you just it's
throwing me off that you're looking at
me because i can only picture what
you're looking at
when you see me
you know i get that way when i didn't
choose to be caught undressed like i
don't like when steve walks in on me
when i'm changing i get really
pissed i get actually like it's not his
fault he doesn't like purposely try to
catch me changing but i feel invaded i
don't know why or like exposed or like i
just need that to be my private time
where like i'm changing and i'm like you
know yeah kind of having my private
moment me too i do not like being locked
in on if i didn't invite it right but
you know when it comes to oh we're
having sex now that like i am like all
one wait wait wait wait wait so i have a
question let's see like
he got out of the shower and you're
changing in the room you know he's in
the house you still feel weird if he
just walks in
yeah wait he got out of the shower let's
say he just got out of the shower and
you're like changing and he caught like
he cut um he caught you naked yeah i um
i yell at him to not come in why yeah
yeah because it's not because
it's not because like
oh i don't want him to see me naked but
it's just those are the times where i'm
judging myself or like self-assessing
myself where like i just got out of the
shower and i'm like i feel a little
bloated today or like whatever and i'm
kind of like
processing my own
like
self-esteem or something what it is
i don't like someone walking in on me
when i'm i haven't you know my
confidence back up yet yeah yeah so that
was me during sex in our early years
like like i was
wanting to have sex wanting to be in the
present moment but i couldn't get the
[ __ ] out of my own head yeah i couldn't
get out of my own insecurity plus early
20s is like that yeah general i feel
like you're getting judged by society
like they're treating you like a sexual
object all the time because they're like
you're young 20s and then you're like
expected to want to be sexy right i felt
a tremendous amount of pressure to
have to project that like they were
telling me today especially in the
industry the entertainment industry the
roles that i was getting sent out for i
actually had to take a poll dancing
class and i've mentioned this before
because i was so
like not confident in my sexuality at
all and um i was raised really religious
and so i took that pole dancing class
and it completely liberated me where i
was like feeling myself i had never
experienced that sort of like my own
sexuality like owning that before and
that was really important for sure it's
super important and i think it all comes
down to the way in which you think of
your body right so i
obviously
so i not obviously but i don't have i
don't relate to that but i'm thinking
about it and it's like well i think i
look good like i love my body i
generally am proud of it like i can
i mean i don't know about naked naked
but i can stand in front of you guys in
like a bikini and be like oh i'm fine
with it like yeah so i think it may be
and the reason why i love my body is
because of the work i've put into it you
know obviously in the gym i've gotten my
boobs done i have made sure that i like
this piece of
work
yeah
do you change your mind on a daily basis
on how you feel about your body no it's
pretty consistent i love my body i think
that's the thing yeah you're consistent
in your views of yourself yeah i'm not
consistent at all yeah and i also like
uh struggle with depression and so if i
just came out of a spout where like i
couldn't even barely
get out of bed i have not been taking
care of myself like i haven't been able
to work out or maybe i haven't even
taken a shower in a few days yeah i feel
gross and i and it feels like even if he
doesn't see me as physically gross i
feel disgusting
and when i look in the mirror it i only
see disgust so what do you think it
would take for you to feel like i love
my body yeah so that's kind of the
process that i go through when i get out
of the shower and or when i'm like naked
where i'm like hey i love because i had
to go through a lot of like that kind of
work
um and i
and i'm for the most part like you can
get there but if i'm having an off day
like i have to go through it you know i
on my own like he can't just walk in on
me randomly
when i'm naked yeah because i'm i'm
trying to build myself back up again
where i'm like hey i love me like i love
this body what would you ever be open to
the idea of helping him or him helping
you build you back up
you know like because obviously he's
your partner you chose him and you love
him and you trust him and you know he
would never disrespect you or your body
regardless of how down you were
um that but also like if he walks in
he's turned on
and i'm not in the mood i'm like trying
to
yeah we go back to the whole thing where
i see it exactly yeah i'm like no i
don't be touched right now
i want to be like i want to get used to
myself in this private moment
for me like having having him build me
up like it's like a separate thing like
i'm like this is work
like this is like my [ __ ] i gotta figure
this out and you're trying to help it's
like it's kind of like when they're
trying to solve your problems yeah where
it's like no no this isn't like i don't
need you to tell me that i'm beautiful i
don't know right now like i just need to
like be okay with me and assess where
i'm at right now with myself and this is
just kind of like a me moment like i
can't have you interrupting it yeah um
but on top of that steve's never knew so
i never see him coming out of the shower
either like i don't catch him naked
randomly i've like hardly ever seen him
naked never knew he was so funny yeah
he always has boxers on i picture him
with a jean shorts from arrest exactly
never even during sex they have issues
yeah there's been a few times where i'm
like let's do a full naked but like it's
not do you never shower together no i
mean we we have before but i like hot
ass showers and he's a little baby like
he needs like a lukewarm shower i'm like
casey we're like [ __ ] is this like i
practiced freezing here
i like that it's healthier for your skin
yeah see
what in your blood flow i know i don't
have good blood flow hot water is bad
for your skin oh it's bad for yourself i
thought you were telling me i was right
no i'm backing stevo
because i'm the lukewarm [ __ ] oh you
are like i thought you were backing my
side no i can't do
hot water
no you're hot water i need hot water
they say that the reason why women love
hot showers because it reminds them of
home because they're deaf they're satan
true
that's funny
no lies exactly my showers are scalding
hot yeah i feel like i just am always
cold i'm a cold person yeah
my extremities are always bone co i see
i'm always a cool person too what the
[ __ ] is
extreme hot is like what the [ __ ] is
that oh i feel like i'm thawing out
no for me i can't take it i'm a little
[ __ ] anyway stacy doesn't really know
about the whole pillow thing what's the
pill this is like old-school tiffany
tiffin case story yeah i don't really
know much about the pillow thing to be
honest what's up
send it so
yeah so the whole pillow thing though
it's because like i mean what i said is
like i would slow like it just evolved
like our sex life kind of evolved where
like i would cut like one time i just
moved the pillow over his face and i'm
like oh [ __ ] that's the solution i feel
better now i feel in it and he liked it
too like i forgot to mention that years
ago but he was [ __ ] into it he liked
it and
i'm like all right cool because then he
it just sounds funny
too
he's just like hell yeah and like he was
just like it was it was like a
[Laughter]
that he thought i was trying to
suffocate him you're good with it yeah
sure then it was like it just became a
part of our sex life for some time [ __ ]
anyone that judges that so then yeah i
shared that and i got hella just people
there but the thing that really bothered
me the most it's like
i didn't know how to properly express
the reason why that even happened and i
just felt so misunderstood and and it
was hurtful too yeah because i'm like
they're like ridiculing me for something
like they're just like poor casey
hashtag poor casey like all the time
hashtag
private moment that you're sharing with
everybody to help relate to other people
and they just use it against me as well
these are also like 16 year olds yeah
never touched anyone before who only
watch porn and think that that's the
only way that anything should be done
yes and so it was really frustrating and
if it okay switch
the hashtag was a trigger thing for me
so you're like bring the hashtag tag
back and i'm like switch it around well
girls that like to be choked is that it
is that like save gina because she likes
me
hashtag save gina
she's like they don't know your man
yeah but like and then also that's just
so insulting to casey like what the [ __ ]
like you don't think that he couldn't
stand up for himself
if he did it
yeah so like that that's a trigger like
that pillow
part of my [ __ ] life that i shared
like it's triggering wait so you guys
don't do it anymore oh no because well
that was kind of part of it i'm just
like yeah i guess this is horrible oh my
god i'm such a horrible person
he's grabbing the pillow and putting it
on himself right it's hilarious i didn't
i've never heard that part before gina
[Laughter]
but yeah like i i guess it really did
affect our [ __ ] sex like these
[ __ ] comments and it wasn't just on
the internet okay it was in person too
so i'm like people bring that up in
person what yes what kind of social
media no dumbass would do that well we
know socially dumb ass people oh my god
so it's just like you know like it was
just really hard to deal with because
i'm like wait i didn't explain it i feel
misunderstood yeah i'm being shamed for
this [ __ ] poor casey well i don't want
to be like i don't want to be [ __ ]
using my boyfriend like holy [ __ ] let me
not do this anymore so i i had to like
work through
on
like having that solution not be a
solution anymore and then me learning
and then also like you know with the
progression of our relationship and like
i got more comfortable with him so it
wasn't like my self
self-conscious body image issues weren't
as big of a deal anymore because we had
already been together for a while
whatever it eventually that faded out
but
[ __ ] hate the hashtag save casey like
yeah that's so hashtag casey was doing
it to himself yeah
why do you think we have somebody here
it was his idea
what do you think's in their baby
registry
[Music]
if i see something a bed or a corner
with a lot of pillows i'm avoiding that
[ __ ]
dude we have a lot of pillows all over
the house actually my garage is filled
with pillows there you go
it's also it's never good to shame
anybody for their sexual exactly you
can't kink shame that's a thing you
don't know you're harming someone and
it's right
against wedding essentially
right yeah because i'm like i [ __ ]
liked the choking thing too but my
windpipe was getting crushed yeah stop
doing it right you squeezed on the side
i don't like that i don't like the
choking because it crushes one pipe but
i do like my mouth being completely
covered and we're like because i like to
make noise but if they force me not to
make noises what if they grab a pillow
and [ __ ]
grapple as long as i can breathe still
like i'm a breathable pillow yeah yeah
as long as their hand is below my
nostrils yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right well thank you guys
so much for watching this episode make
sure to give this video a thumbs up hope
you learned a lot you're not alone out
there there's a lot of people getting
interrupted mentally with sex so just
get it take that [ __ ] your thoughts out
completely normal it's something we all
go through as women and men as well and
apparently no farting yeah
yeah that's i recommend it highly
recommend it me too yeah and make sure
to follow stacy
you can find her links in the
description box down below to her
channel you can check out her beautiful
jewelry line thank you and everything
she's working on and we love you i love
you love you bye bye bye